you are amazing for coming out tonight
thank you so much for joining us this is
simulation my name is Alan Saki on so
how many of you guys have been to a
simulation event before yeah okay cool
cool how many is the first one a couple
yeah there we go
good stuff so all right simulations
rebirthing the public intellectual
inspiring you to build the future we do
so through a multidisciplinary daily
show and live event series and we hope
to fill sports stadiums with curious
intellectuals so we'll get there
together all right now this is our first
production called women and alliance we
are super excited for this is coming at
an incredibly crazy time it's just nuts
that it's so landed to be on this time I
have a deep amount of respect for women
and especially three women that are
joining us tonight it's just an just
it's a pleasure to be able to be with
just strong women that are leaving their
stamp on earth and that's what we're
doing here we're gonna be having a
panelist discussion about that and about
the importance then how we can help
actualize women into our world and
integrate some of the trauma that we've
went through and I am looking forward to
this discussion with you and we'll have
some Q&A at the end as well so get ready
for some cool Q&A and all right let's
introduce Alan first from work-wise and
Alan is gonna come and say a couple
words Thank You Alan welcome at work
wise it's so exciting to have simulation
vacuum and our location here again
tonight's panel in particular is one
that I've been looking forward to for a
long time as diversity within the
workplace and particularly for us a very
early stage business it's been super
hard to actually get and to achieve
diversity around race not so difficult
for us but gender balance across an
early stage companies be incredibly
difficult and it's something very close
to my heart so so excited to have ladies
here
tastic to have simulation here again and
just come in part of the where we are
intersecting between the changes in the
way of work the changes in
organizational structures and a real
movement around how we need to become
very human centric in our workspace and
in our lives so right anymore
I'll pass back over to the panel thank
you thanks our move and we've had
several comments already today about
people walking and going okay what is
this place this place is amazing and
they're really at the cutting edge of
the future of work check them out work
wise calm all right so let's go ahead
and introduce our panelists okay so
we're gonna start over here with Mariana
saenko all right as a principal at
Khosla Ventures and she was formerly at
D F J and there is so much more to
unpack but focus aerospace future of
food robotics so all right let's keep it
up for Mariana whoo and we have McKenzie
slaughter joining us in the middle
McKenzie is a founder of beyond Capital
Markets and pro Hoffs capital as well
and also lot of focus on blockchain and
crypto and social impact round of
applause and lastly we have Nicole
Bradford at the end
Nicole's executive director of the
transformative technology lab and she's
also a forum at the willow group as well
founder will group and also formerly at
Blizzard so exciting stuff was given to
Cole round of applause all right so
thank you for joining us and then yep
click and we're good to go and McKenzie
awesome beautiful okay I feel like we
should take a moment to just you know
I'm so cerebral myself I'm always in my
head so when I have the opportunity to
just you know take a breath and get into
my body in my heart a little more if you
guys want to join me
huge thank you for coming everyone and
especially you three your huge role
models to me and to so many others and I
am blessed to be able to pass respect to
you and I recently was taught that by
someone that a very powerful woman that
I know that she cares more about being
respected would you maybe touch on that
a little bit as we enter into the first
part of the conversation which is about
what is going on in the world with the
feminine energy coming into more places
in our on in our work in our
relationships in our business and in
technology and what that is looking like
whatever order you maybe it's cuz I work
in venture capital I think respect is
something that everybody craves and it's
not gender biased right it's just that I
think that there are certain groups that
are disenfranchised for one reason or
another and one of the ways that we show
[Music]
aggression as humans in self-similar
groups versus you know us versus other
is by disrespect and so I think that in
in our environments and our social
environments and our family environments
and our work environments we aim to feel
included and that inherently means some
level of respect and so I don't actually
think respect is a gender thing because
I'm more often see like for me I feel
more disrespected because I'm young
sometimes in my profession and because
I'm a female
and honestly I found that it's really
nice to be in a technical profession or
have a technical background because you
can slap someone into reality real fast
by just saying I don't really care what
your preconceptions of me are but here
the here are the 10 reasons that you're
wrong and
and I can derive it from first
principles if you need but that's a
privilege of my position and my
profession and the work I do and I
gather that that's that can be very
difficult depending on how you place
yourself in the world okay well I think
that respect is not it's not a moral
standard these days I think people when
you meet people whether it's work or or
in your personal life they just
sometimes not everybody sometimes they
just don't sometimes if the bars it's
not that very high when you first meet
someone so it's our goal as individuals
not just women but it's our goal with
individuals to teach people how they
should treat you when you first meet
them and so that's how I respect because
I get I get all kind of responses based
on my industry in my industry and
finance and technology so I'm not
supposed to look like this in this space
so I get inundated with that I get you
know it's a male-dominated industry so I
get inundated with that and and so I
don't I'm not the stereotype so you just
have to be Stern don't have to be rude
or anything like that it's just you know
you just kind of show people who you are
in the very beginning and I think that's
how you get respect and then be
consistent about it two years ago
I think that's how you get that respect
I would say if I had to choose between a
respect and access to opportunity access
to education and capital I would take
the opportunity I don't have to be
friends with people so it's really more
about you know it's it's not it's really
it's you know it's not a desire it's not
an insistence on equal outcomes it's an
existent unequal opportunity because if
I have the opportunity I'm going to get
it done and so ideally yes
you know I would love to have respectful
working relationships with people and I
would I would love to have that but you
know I think one of the things that we
are you know we're in the transition
right now I think this is a really big
transition time and I actually do think
so do you think things that things are
changing social norms are changing this
is what I call the crunch in a lot of
different areas and so you know it's got
to be uncomfortable for some people but
it's really all about getting access to
the opportunity in order to you know
create the companies and the programs
that can actually change the world and
that matters to me more than you know
whether or not someone's nice to me
that's a really great answer that we we
absolutely need the equality of
opportunity for for for everyone to be
able to pursue what actualizes them into
the world and that might even trump
respect then it's a good answer and then
you we started kind of endeavoring into
the even before we endeavor into the
transition there was also the comment
about just what we do about teaching the
children that are coming into the world
about respect and the golden rule of
treating others how you want to be
treated
okay let's unpack the transition more so
what do you see happening in the
workplace I mean Nicole you were just
rattling off numbers to me earlier about
the amount of females that hold
leadership positions now in the
these that that are in your ecosystem
and that also have are either investors
or the co-founders this is all very
exciting stuff and same thing with the
organizations that you two are working
with so tell us about this transition
and what that is bringing into society
yeah so just to give everybody context I
work in what we call transformative
technology and so that is tech that is
designed to support mental health
emotional well-being and human thriving
and so specifically that's mental health
stress anxiety depression for emotional
well-being that's happiness loneliness
connection meaning making
social-emotional skills the ability to
emotionally self-regulate self-awareness
and then on human thriving that's
actually really expanding the mental and
emotional capacity of humans so that can
be everything from brain computer
interface to brain to brain
communication all of the things that
would take down the friction and society
and it expand what humans are capable of
being and doing and so important to note
that two-thirds of those things are not
about you know are not about issues it's
about what's possible for Humanity so
it's not just mental health sometimes
people think it's just mental health
it's broader than that and the reason
why I give that background is that we
just finished we have a lab a conference
in the Academy and we just finished a
global call for entrepreneurs and
innovators who are interested in this
area because I was getting emails from
people all over the world so I had the
sense that it was global and that's
proven to be true we recruited over a
thousand people and they're from 69
countries 450 cities 20% of them are
what we call and we categorized as
entrepreneurs and to do that we had a
high bar they had to have a very clearly
defined transformative technology
product and they had to be working on it
full-time and then the rest are
innovators who are interested from
places and everyone's from places that
you might not expect we had quite a lot
of people from Africa
Southeast Asia like outside of what
people traditionally think but for our
entrepreneurs I'm really excited about
these stats I had them you know updated
and calculated for today for our
entrepreneurs 50 percent had one female
founder 50 percent of the companies had
one female founder defined as more than
ten percent of equity eighty-six percent
twenty five percent of the staff or
female fifty nine percent had one female
investor eighty-four percent have one
female advisor and forty eight percent
have one female external board member
and I think what's really important
about this is that it wasn't a gendered
call you know and say hey all the women
who are interested in transformative
technology we said we are interested in
the future of human possibility in the
future of the human mind
and this is who responded to that call
which we you know did a lot of serious
networking throughout all the tech
ecosystems to find these people and so I
think what's happening to get back to
the original you know question about
what the transition and the crunch that
we're in is that we are in a period of
time where the stakes are very high and
I think you know lots of people most
about those stakes yeah well I think
lots of people recognize when the stakes
are high but I think especially women
also recognize when the stakes are high
what are you women are actually engaged
in that what are the stakes well I mean
the biggest stakes I think that it's
coming is that the I mean there's a the
one of your questions is sort of like
what are the three biggest problems so
I'm kind of jumping ahead but those are
the stakes so one is the future of the
human mind which I'll dig into in a
second the other one is climate and the
things driving it so energy generation
food production and waste disposal and
then the other one is the you know
economic structure and a lot of the
things that are being pushed on by the
rise of automation and what that's going
to do to the future of work and what
it's going to take to be employable in
the future and and the you know the the
social instability that's possible but
not deterministic we can do something
about it and so the future of the human
mind is the thing that really makes the
difference
and you know it's it's probably also the
root cause of everything else so you
don't get to solve those other problems
without addressing the human mind and so
that's why I think we have so many women
who are interested and will impact that
as we go what about you guys on
transition oh wow follow up on that
before I forget my thought but this
state yes the stakes are high
but I also think that women are agents
of change and so economically the states
are high for everyone but it's women
that's really really filling really
filling the pain I'm gonna try to do
this in order and that be sporadic but
just to give you some background on me
I've I've been in FinTech or financial
innovation for the past ten years I
started be on capital markets back in
2010 a year after my first company of
house capital which is an alternative
investment firm beyond capital markets
started out as doing research and then
we kind of doing research for hedge
funds and private equity funds and then
we kind of pivoted into fintechs of a
background in tech and started coding at
NASA Langley I was 18 and it also having
and being in finance so kind of put
those two together one of the projects
we have a lab at poorhouse capital for
house laughs which is a fin type lab one
of our biggest projects today is beauty
in the bowl which is a social trading
platform for women that we started
around 2012 launched in 2013 we had a
really hard time with adoption or a
really hard time with the dot women are
busy when they have a lot going on so it
was a it's been a struggle but when
cryptocurrency came around all these
women wanted to just invest immediately
they just immediately got it and
something just snapped in our brains and
and we just women just innately
understand cryptocurrency I don't think
the stock market is organic to us from
my observations and in finance but I
think because of this cryptocurrency and
blockchain way
what I'm also seeing with women and
being agents of change in this economic
transition that we're going through I do
I am bullish on watching cryptocurrency
obviously but but also I see women
wanting to be fund managers analyst and
and really doing the grunt work that
it's going to take to get our government
to start acting like civilized a
civilized government and make you know
civilized regulations and so we don't
look like an embarrassment globally
which is what we do right now so how we
look right now but it's the wing of that
are worse people than us I don't think
so but anyway that's just my opinion
but I think women want to are open and
kind of used to doing the grunt work
right and being that foundation so envy
on capital markets we do a lot of things
right now we are focused on two things
we have an investment fund platform
where we focus on tokenizing funds so
anything from a hedge fund or a venture
capital fund or a real estate fund we
tokenize that on the blockchain we also
have an academy because it's really
important to educate the investors and
also create analysts just to create the
infrastructure their operational
infrastructure of this industry if we
want to be taken seriously and yesterday
believe it or not I was in New York City
I had an event with with s AP and a con
and I promoted this beyond Academy that
we have which is a certification program
to become a blockchain analyst or a fund
manager and I got this big rush and it
was mostly women so and and they shared
their stories with me some of them you
know just moved here with the background
in private equity but they want to do so
so good they don't know where to go
because there's no companies out there
there's no finance companies out there
that want to be socially good all the
time
maybe you maybe once in a while and
there's some women that are accountants
or some there are data scientists and
they want to figure out how to make
social impact filtered into finance and
investing so so I think women are the
future maybe it is a sign of the times
the position of the Sun in the moon
whatever but you know if I think it's
our time and I think it's our time I
think the first part is going to be
finance because that's the biggest pain
everyone's having right now and then
from there everything will kind of flow
both from there so I agree with you
climate change is really big and
agriculture and food security is really
really good you're making you realize
how maybe if not jaded extremely
constrained my worldview is because I've
literally the exact opposite experience
in the blockchain space okay which is
most of the women who I know who are in
venture capital are running in the other
direction from it and very very few of
the like of the projects that come and
pitch to me for start-up equity or first
like shaft simpler gary means for future
tokens which is a slightly nonsense
documentation but we can talk about that
at some point very few there's just no
protections on either side like it's a
very weird but like you know cross your
fingers and and pray to whoever your
preferred DNA is that the whole thing
works out the but I have very few
experiences of female like lots of
amazing female founders and lots of
industries particularly and anything to
do with like brain mind health stuff but
when it comes to blockchain literally
zero it's crazy to me it's like I think
I've met one woman in the last year who
came and pitched what for me was kind of
an interesting project but the rest of
them it's like the most stereotypical
everyone kind of looks the same yeah Jax
I'm like curious that we I mean the
funds the crypto funds that we're
raising for is a hundred
percent 2% men but it's the women that
we're talking to see where ecosystem
builders so we're talking to women that
you would never think had an interest in
blockchain they're not necessarily
techies or founders yeah and we don't
have a lot of women in blockchain that
are founders and building gaps and all
that stuff and I think that I don't have
a problem with that because if we're
building everything around it that
supports that that supports their
companies and and it gets them to be the
next fund managers or board members or
or whoever I think those I counter you
on that point I think I have a massive
problem with it because groups
inherently create bias and like it's
nobody's fault right if you just sit
around the table and everyone has the
same perspective you just build bias
into the thing that you're building
right this is super common in AI groups
I run into this all the time where
people were like I don't know I have
this great facial recognition system it
works perfectly and it's like yeah it's
because you your test net was all of the
white dudes who work in your office and
so when you put anyone of color or any
gender it doesn't work at all right and
it fails in catastrophic ways so I worry
about this particularly when it comes to
distributed systems because the way that
we think about like social trust systems
multi-layered like party hierarchy I
think it falls naturally into some of
the inherent rules and constructs that
we navigate in certain societies by and
then when you pick up that team and
you're like great but now we're gonna
first deploy this in Singapore or
Colombia or wherever else it just
culturally fails in all sorts of
basically catastrophic fashions and I
think a lot of that is because on the
tech side we have very very little
diversity in these projects and so
people aren't thinking about the larger
implementation challenge right so I
agree with you on that but I still think
we're tackling a project the problem in
the wrong way I've been I'm a part of
the problem or have been a part of the
problem so I figured it out
but I think we've been doing a bottom
top yeah that's right bottom on top
approach and and I don't know just one
day I was thinking what if I focused on
the top and deeply appreciate what
you're doing like about it I just don't
like having me also like if I'm working
from the bottom how do I help you I'm
gonna tell you my other company for
house capital we decided over these
years we were kind of toying with
creating this big FinTech VC fund and
being venture capitalist because
everybody wants to be a venture
capitalist right but what the what the
real opera real opportunity is is being
a capital provider so we decided to just
go for it and so we're raising a 1
billion dollar fund of funds and with
that we have education as well people
need to be educated and so we've been
working with state pensions that were
mandate they state Pinchas and insurance
companies etc they have these mandates
that they have to work with women in
minority by managers or our investment
analysts or whatever so we're using that
strategy and if we can raise 1 billion
dollars in front of that money down to
two women like you female fund managers
or female investment professionals then
that will hopefully change the bias from
the top and then the founders will be
forced to change or they don't get any
money so so we have a and there was a
good conversation of good counters I
like that and the with within within the
transition we have we have some problems
that we see in problems that we want to
solve and augment to make it better and
we also have really good experiences
maybe we talk about some personal
experiences that we think are moving us
in the right direction some of the
things that we're like still
face-palming we'd love to unpack a
little bit of that
good experiences with the transition
transition well you know like it's
interesting the other day I was at I
meditated a lot and and so one of the
things that comes from one of the
practices that I get is that I can kind
of tell and I'm getting triggered about
something really fast before it even
happens and I find that one of the
things that that triggers me a little
bit is statements about men are like
this and women are like that or these
are masculine traits or these are
feminine traits and this is the feminine
this is the masculine I because whenever
I look at that list a lot of the a lot
of the traits that say masculine or just
like stuff I do every day
you know and I'm like but I don't feel
masculine and I you know like I reject
that or you know my my father was my
primary caregiver for many years while
my mother wasn't in law school and one
of his points of pride was you know
braiding my hair without a crooked you
know a crooked scalp you know it's so I
have like this like my experience of um
you know the man who raised me along
with my mother was incredibly nurturing
and incredibly hands-on and you know and
so loving and a man you know and so I
just think you know I think that the one
of the things that I'm I'm glad that
seems to be coming you know being
addressed a little bitter or changing is
that I think that these definitive
descriptions about this is men or like
this and women are like this I think you
know I think it's it's it's unfair to
women because it creates a double
standard for you know how women can
behave and how men can behave and I also
think that it stifles men too in the
sense that you know there are a lot of
men with extraordinarily juicy hearts
and I don't think that that means that
like why is that feminine why is that
not masculine
but extraordinarily juicy heart and so
like that juicy heart yeah and so I
think I think a lot of that stuff is
starting that's starting to shift and
not just on the the coast you know I see
it in different places and I cover a lot
of I cover a lot of ground because I'm a
scanner and I scan for sort of like you
know cultural trends social trends and
and you know I would say if I you know
someone said what's your superpower it's
that I feel like I have a sense of snow
I can feel when I can tell when
something's coming by looking at all of
these social trends and so it's
something that you see happening and so
I think that's a big part of the
transition and that gives me a lot of
encouragement and there's so many men
who are standing up there's so many men
who are there's so many male you know
allies to this idea of you know equal
access to opportunity and so I'm really
I'm really inspired and I also am really
there are things that that I'm really
encouraged by and I'm gonna say
something maybe I shouldn't do it
cameras yes so okay I'm just gonna say
it but you have to whoever you are
watching on the internet you have to
listen to the whole thing it's basically
that I don't find Jordan Peterson
offensive and the reason why is because
I don't agree with anything he said I
don't agree with anything he says well
there's some things he blends a lot of
stuff but what he does what what what he
says to me is that humanity is hungry
for a new narrative humanity is hungry
for a new narrative the historical
structures have passed away if you look
at the Edelman Trust index and what
people used to believe in things are
changing
even faith in you know religion
government's higher education as
salvation you know if you think of all
the people who are in debt for you talk
to college students in America about how
they feel about higher education I
believe in the higher education but I'm
just saying it's like if you look at
what people trust in what they believe
in the sand is shifting and so when I
see you know this person who I don't
agree with but the enthusiasm for what
he has to say I see that as enthusiasm
for a new narrative people are looking
for something and they're looking for a
structure and I think that at the point
that we can do we can collectively come
up with you know a new narrative for
Humanity for Team human and what this
all is about I think the ability to
cause or to have a collective shift is
actually easier than it has been
historically and so what I see when I
look at the social swirls not just in
the US because I track things all over
the world is there's a confluence of
need demand and means for shifting the
human mind and I think that is a you
know that it has to go along with
economics and has to go along with other
things but I think we have an
opportunity and you know it isn't the
the future of the world is not written
but it's being written right now and so
I think this is the most exciting time
and one of the most important times to
be alive humanities hungry for a new
narrative like oh yeah and the future is
being built right now and you said you
took a very you know international
approach to how things were in Mariana I
think I heard you a little bit play with
this when you said that there are places
in the world where things are still
worse and I and I do firmly believe that
that to be very true and that we are
moving those standards up but the United
States is absolutely not
the worst
and but we could be a better role model
and this is what we're discussing now so
with the narrative how being hungry for
a new narrative I'd like to open up for
you two to speak on that for a little
bit what do you think about that
what do you think that looks like my
answers very short I'm just happy to see
women not getting in their own way
anymore
getting in their own way not getting in
their own way women get in their own way
and do you think that's you think that's
the fear and courage that that type of
she kind of goes back to exactly what
she said she explained it very well it
goes back to those female versus male
stereotypes right so if women followed
these along I'm a girl so I need to do
this stereotypes they kind of become
their own enemy and they fall into these
traps and if for me it sees these
overtly emotional traps that I see a lot
of women get into especially when it
comes to their Armani behaviors um you
know I see that a lot but I see us
changing and kind of evolving and taking
a leadership role were a natural born
leader so and I think with that stigma
and just exactly how you said it that's
going away so we don't have to kind of
feed into these social norms that that
we're holding us back all this time so I
think I'm the pessimist in the group
because the the thing I fear at the end
of the day is the the transfer of
information is the right the friction
for a transfer and ruination is just
falling precipitously it's so easy to
tweet something or create a meme and
then like half the world has retweeted
it and has engrained it permanently and
they're like essence of being in 36
hours and it's insane and it's the
reason I don't tweet right because the
concept that you have like one sentence
which is basically I don't know how some
people think very deeply about their
tweets I'm not capable about it and then
you know it's in green forever
like this you know 240 characters or
whatever totally out of context forever
and it's it's your one truth that you
will be held against and so the thing
that I fear at the end of the day in in
this new world a new narrative that
we're moving in is that we have far
fewer trusted sources of information and
we are rebelling against this hierarchy
of information and we are rebelling
against journalism and like thoughtful
opinion pieces that are dual sided and
so when when we move into a media
culture that that goes from highly
curated and very carefully disseminated
for poor risk right and Jefferson
basically said this country is going to
be built on a postal system because it's
how actually we'll get people to vote
and that's how you have to get
information out to them and I will
subsidize the newspapers for as long and
that it has that has to happen but that
will only works when you actually have
very curated storytelling and in a world
where everyone gets to be their own
publisher and scream their own truth you
have so much disinformation and I just
the number of people I meet who say
insane things and then when you press
them on it you cannot have a logical
argument there's no reasonable discourse
because they're like I don't believe
that you're like this is true like
there's nothing to believe or just
believe it's factually correct and
they're like I don't believe that and
it's men and women and it freaks me out
I'm so scared you're talking about
epistemic inconsistency that's a word
that I've been using now to talk about
Steve I can trust on Alan to just
explain mistis Tamala Jesus study of
what's justified truth versus just
what's belief and so there's a society
is dealing with a just an unstable
unstable level of epistemic
inconsistency so you can't decipher as
you've pointed out that the friction of
information transfers to the lowest it's
ever been it's only going lower and and
and I'm happy that you bring up
epistemic inconsistency because it is
one of the things that I'm also
concerned with and then how does that
you know how how would you say that
relation to the transition well I think
that the thing that I fear is
transitions are not at the end of the
day humans are like these very
interesting pack animals right and like
leaders arise and small groups gather
around them and and pockets intersect in
interesting ways and and we still
struggle to share like empathy with each
other and so you just end up with these
little cohorts and so what I worry is
that the heads of those cohorts end up
telling the stories that promote their
own narratives and so while I do think
that we're seeing a greater rise in the
diversity of narratives I'm not seeing a
rise and like the quality of narrative
oh really good so so you know terms of
if we think about it in terms of really
powerful nodes on a network the these
really powerful nodes that exist in many
cases are propagating the stories that
they are finding to be most impactful or
influential and sometimes it's really
important to take note information from
notes that are linked to us to help
build a greater narrative one that's
even recognize that we're talking like
three abstraction layers really like and
so and I'm sorry that you know it's like
a Friday night and I went there but I
think that if I if I give like a
grounded example I have peers in a third
group in Eastern Europe and I have
brilliant peers in in of course kind of
still back home and when I'll chat with
them about their worldview like you know
my friends in Ukraine are having a hard
time because their country's at war and
no one talks about it and then my
friends in Russia so deeply believed
that those guys in Ukraine are just
idiots and basically deserve to be
subservient and these are not
unintelligent people these are just
people for whom the propaganda has been
so force-fed for so long that it doesn't
register as anything other than a native
truth and it's free that's horrifying
right and you only get that if that like
perspective of distance but I know for
myself because I'm a part of that social
group which is if I grew up in that part
of Russia with those people I don't know
that I would have a different
perspective in the same
you'd have the same roll of dice that is
very scary that the mind is so malleable
and then if you're force-fed though
those lies that probably I'd love to say
that I'd be above it but realistically
yeah we would all have fallen into the
trap of the Nazi Germany type you know
we would have all right there's got real
dark real fast and so yeah I'm glad I'm
glad we brought up epistemic
inconsistency but Nicole yes I think
there's a couple of things so there's
more to it great there's more to it yes
please a couple of things is that so
like we wanted so one of the questions
that you sent to us was like what do you
believe is true that less than 1% of the
population believes it's true and you
know one of the things so because in my
line of work you know often when I speak
and I speak a lot people there's a sense
of nostalgia that people have they're
like oh you know things used to be good
so like tech people are like before
Facebook and then other people are like
before tech and everyone's got this
thing that like things used to be great
I don't think things used to be great
you know so I'm an african-american
female and to get to great I'd have to
go back to matrilineal Africa on the
Serengeti and everything between then
and now sucked yeah so it didn't used to
be great or people like we used to be
deeply in community and it's like well
yeah a lot of a lot of domestic violence
happened in those communities a lot of
other things that couldn't be discussed
happened those communities so it isn't
but I don't believe in throwing the baby
out with the bathwater but a really big
thing is that around the world we have
never really been taught how to truly
connect with one another we haven't
really been taught and those are the
skills of the future and so I don't
really mean it in sort of like a
touchy-feely unpack a wagged oh yeah
yeah yeah the unpacking so
you know yeah so like do you know the
big the big frame works so let's just
you know like a lot of the big
historical frameworks you know the the
extent of human interaction except in a
couple of the esoteric branches where
it's out shalt not blank but how do you
really really connect because and this
is where I will you know tie back to
what you're saying is that you know I
truly believe and you know and from when
you sort of look at what people really
if you deconstruct a lot of what people
are saying or a lot of what people are
doing and I just was talking to someone
who did is done a study on you know
teens who do school shootings and what
are they really looking for you know so
much of it comes back to belonging and
connection and so you know one of the
things that is interesting that's
happening with you know the way a lot of
our science is expanding right now is
you know the Darwinistic point of view
of competition is now starting to be
challenged and one great example is you
know the secret life of trees and what
actually happens in the forest there's a
huge amount of nature that is
collaborative and then everyone here
who's in this room or watching who's
going to watch this on camera your
ancestors were extraordinary at
collaboration they could compete but
they also were great at collaboration
and so there's a whole section of our
nature's that are not amplified yet by
technology and I don't think technology
is the solution by the way like I don't
think it's this panacea but we have a
very one-dimensional sort of a approach
we're in the stone Age's of what's
coming
and so in terms of like where people are
at and how people so quickly you know
believe the worst of others that is the
skill level that they're at
that's where they're at will they always
be that way I don't think so because I
think that the higher I think that
there's a larger percentage of human
nature that desires to connect you
started with respect respect is that is
an indication of belonging those who non
belong died on the Serengeti so I think
it's a really big chunk of ours and if
we actually skill people if we actually
learn and I don't know what these
products are I don't know how we do it
yet I know we don't do it at scale in
our society today I know that the skills
that you know are related to connecting
to one another are going to be the core
for being able to be compensated in any
way whether it's tokens or something
else in the future and that anyone who
doesn't have those skills will become
irrelevant and that is like one of the
biggest issues that we have so I'm
incredibly optimistic but I have a sense
of urgency and the futures not written
and you know and it could go badly but
you know what else do you do with your
time on earth so for both being off
because you guys are on different ends
which is good do you think that women
are have the abilities are these the
characteristics to kind of bring this
change forth from from up from I guess
like empathy bringing empathy into the
world and compassion into the world you
think that women are leading that or is
it just non gender issue I just talked
for a long time so why don't you go I
I would like the answer to be that it's
non gendered because I think that that
that actually creates a sustainable
solution so I think for me what we're
I'm extremely optimistic is that
particularly Western societies are
becoming far more amenable to different
definitions of self and so right like we
have I'm right in the last ten years
I've learned all these new words for
sis non-gendered like yeah right the
whole spectrum and I apologize to all
those people that I don't know all of
your vocabulary as well as I should but
I think that as we gain more acceptance
for different ways in which people
decide to define themselves and the
space that they kind of take up that
that's who ends up leading the charge
right is the people who it's I would
almost say that it's going to come from
that community in the communities that
are closest to it rather than our
classic definition of male-female in the
sense that you almost have to be more on
the fringe to like raise the flag and
say no no this actually looks
fundamentally different if you're going
to connect with me you have to like lay
all that stuff on the side and and have
a very open conversation that is gonna
be out of your comfort zone and you're
not going to know what pronoun to use
and that's fine and and I see that
happening and and right in my own very
very tiny sliver world view is that like
a lot of the woman I run into are some
of the toughest people I've ever worked
with because I had this this woman tell
me once that like you know she basically
put on armor every day and you know
wasn't actually like a chainmail but it
really felt like armor for her and then
she was a very different person in her
working life and in her work and a lot
of the female mentors that I've had have
absolutely felt like that person and so
what I fear is that for some of the
women who are in some higher echelon
like particularly in academia not only
are they not leading the charge but they
are like raising the next generation
that is not going to lead the charge
because they've learned how to function
very well in a world that doesn't accept
them and I do think there's a second way
of coming but I I just I would I would
like it to be more of a but kind of
bipartisan approach but yeah wouldn't
that be great you know just kind of
linked hands and said like let's have a
more open conversation yeah tonight
quick on the way
the like the sustainability aspect of
that which is that moving forward
together is the most sustainable and
then also just Nicole what you mentioned
earlier about the the way that trees
you're pointing at the way that they
engage and share resources and help one
another under soil systems and even the
way that we could potentially learn from
things like that and incorporate that
into the way that we cooperate versus
compete or how do we have a symbiosis
between those two things that seems to
be a lot of the transition that we're
talking about is competition and
cooperation figuring out a symbiosis
there were you kind of directing a
little bit of energy towards figuring
that out as part of the transition well
I mean I I think that I think that that
is I think that that's what's happening
and you know I think that you know so
like one of the things that an article
that I read the other day that was just
it was a last year it was kind of crazy
and if and this is only known it's only
approached in mice models it hasn't been
proven in humans in any way at all but
basically it was a guy to make it a very
brief explanation it was a guy who was
genetically engineering mice and wasn't
getting the yield from of the genetic
trait that he was trying to get that one
should statistically get and it opened
up this entire level of inquiry that the
that the mouse egg might be choosing you
know because like statistically he
should have had a higher yield but
something was happening and then he
called up everybody else who was doing
mouse models and they all assumed that
their yield issues had to do with
something else and I only pulled that
forward as an example of you know we
have so many beliefs about how things
are that are based on
a very limited view of how you know our
world works how our bodies work how you
know our social signaling to one another
actually works how nature works and
these things are you know have really
defined you know competition of the
fittest well it's actually the most
adaptable and it doesn't there's
actually a whole lot of you know it's
competition of the most collaborative in
many ways and so I think that we have
these things that we've hung our whole
belief systems on that aren't actually
true or only partially true and so I
think that that is starting to change I
think one of the other things that's
going to have a huge impact is the life
extension and you know one of the things
that's about to happen you know Mary Lou
and I were at the brain mind summit and
one of the people taught us as were you
you know very soon you're gonna have
people families where you have five
generations alive at the same time
that's even before we get into the you
know the crazy life extension of humans
living a hundred and eighty to two
hundred years like within the next ten
years you'll have five generations alive
at the same time never happened before
and so I think you know when we start to
have longer life life spans you know the
the idea of like what is gender what are
relationships a lot of other things are
going to be on the table and it still
again comes back to we have no skills
we have no skills we have no social
skills we haven't really explored how to
do this you have to be you have to be
extremely lucky to get people who teach
you how to truly connect and that's a
problem for Humanity and so a really
great application of you know technology
and education is to start to work on
that and if we can do that then maybe we
get out of having these polarized you
know in abilities to
to one another because once you can
actually talk to another person you
discover that you have way more in
common with them
you know then you don't then not in
terms of being a human and then that's
really how and and I don't think empathy
is a you know I I don't think that it's
a gendered thing I think women are
allowed to have it more than men but I
know plenty of men and you know and
month
my daddy was from Mississippi and I grew
up in Texas and I was surrounded by a
lot of men who had giant juicy hearts so
it's not you know about you know like
West Coast men or San Francisco guys you
know it's not like it's not that at all
and so I think things are changing but
you know it's just that we're in the
crunch it's happening now what's your
last question sir miss Mackenzie how can
we best inspire and respect women that
are coming of age incredible things I
don't think it really matters if you get
respect or not you said that in the very
beginning I mean I'd like respect yeah I
mean we'd like respect but you're not
going to get but if you choose I'll take
opportunity yeah you're not gonna get it
from everybody and it's something that
I'm experiencing too with all the all
these things that we're doing and beyond
capital markets too and you know some
people respect with me and telling my
business partner she's female too we're
two females doing things that people
when we talk to people it's like they
look at us like we got four heads they
just don't understand like how these two
black women are doing all these
incredible things you know we're working
in the Eastern Caribbean we're writing
the you know helping to write the
legislation for new securities laws in
the Eastern Caribbean that governs a
countries including the British Virgin
Islands and you know in the Caribbean is
statistically about men
you know their culture is about its it's
heavily men and it's the men that do
these things and it's to two women that
are you know that are doing these things
instead so I think for us when we're
just used to not having we're used to
being criticized we're used to not
getting that respect from the people
that we want to get it from our we'll
get it from them way later down the road
it has something that has to be earned
and so I would tell women to just be
patient and also just just learn to be
comfortable in your own skin I think
that's the most important thing over
patience just learn it spend more time
with yourself and learn - I'm only child
so I did that a lot so I'm more than
okay with myself and I would say I'm the
best person that I know I'm not
narcissistic it's just the only child
thing but it's McKenzie whatever yeah
but yeah I think more of them I think
women don't spend enough time alone and
with themselves and being comfortable in
their own in their own skin and so I
would say that would be my my
recommendation then what would a society
you look like ideally that could help
foster that sort of comfortability in
their own skin that spend more time with
self work yeah how do you how do you do
that how do you embrace that or how do
you promote that in a society that's a
really good question I have no idea
Mariano's I would say whatever she's
doing it sounds really cool they
transform me I need more of that I think
we need more more that I do meditate a
lot every day as well I think that helps
a lot I think that traveling helps
learning and seeing how other people
live is it's very important traveling in
socioeconomics yeah a difference yeah
yeah and then like for me because I've
just been in the Caribbean so much that
was a big eye-opener for me because I'm
just the most basic American you could
think of Starbucks in the morning
you know I I stress shop at Target
I need my brands I need you know I need
a white picket fence I need there to be
structure and clean like I like America
you know I like that part of America and
then you go to the Caribbean and you see
people that are beyond poor and they
Bluff you see people beyond poor and
right side you see people in these
really nice resorts they're like what
the heck this is really not this is not
how nobody on this planet is supposed to
be living so we have that right here
with Rincon Hill and yeah the Tenderloin
we have there right here yeah when I
when when the uber dropped me off
because I did over what is that over
Express Paula winner when they drop you
off down the street not where you
supposed to be it was like a homeless
convention that they dropped me and I'm
like wait what what what is this where's
my hotel but that should not be
happening hopefully that will you know
hopefully that will go away with more
people being conscious about and more
self-aware and aware of other people as
well about you guys what do you think
there was a lot in that and I I'm almost
gonna like it especially your your
ending come and say I deeply agree I
think that we're entering several
transition periods like we're entering a
really interesting transition period in
the US where every subsequent generation
will not do as well or better than the
prior maybe maybe but like like the
middle-class America in the next short
like this next couple decades are gonna
be very interesting it's not inherently
obvious that you will have with so much
foreign investment particularly coming
into real estate it becomes really
really hard for lower socioeconomically
stabilized families to have the same
access to buy homes and to gain equity
through real estate and so I do think
that there is going to be some and like
maybe it'll get better if you game out
the system long enough but I think in
this next
I know 50 hundred years you're gonna see
an interesting transition where you're
gonna see a generation that had every
expectation to do significantly better
than their parents and might not and
that's not gonna be true everywhere and
it's slightly olestra on the coast well
it's actually very true on the coast
right like who can afford a house in San
Francisco it's great right and so I
think that that's gonna lead to a whole
bunch of interesting social challenges
and social awareness --is and a
different gaming out of people's
expectations and roles in society I
think one thing that I'm extremely
optimistic about is I'm a mentor and
like the first robotics programs and I
spend a lot of time love them working
with particularly with young women in
the robotic space because it's a
something I care deeply about and I was
you know the only person in my class I
was alone I was taking them and that
wasn't that long ago and I find that
really frustrating and now I turn around
and is like there's a team in a co-ed
school where the entire kind of varsity
robotics team is all girls and they're
crushing right and it's not because they
were like championed or told that they
should participate more it's because
they were actually smarter and they were
just right they just did better and so
like in a blind selection process you
have these teams coming forward I think
the thing that frustrates me to no one
just does everybody like remember that
google manifesto that guy wrote where
he's like oh women are actually less
capable of doing math it's he wrote a
lot more than that but that was the gist
of it I actually printed it out just so
I could throw it against a wall and then
I felt really bad about all the trees
but I was so angry I was so livid and I
was like I cannot believe I live in a
time where you know a social peer of
mine like not that we're friends but
like the guys probably about my age and
I just I was like man I'm gonna I'm just
gonna physically strangle him if I ever
run into him and that's not acceptable
at all but I think the thing that I
freaked out about and the and I like I
literally lost my mind that was not like
a same person the week that that came
out and all the half-baked news stories
around it but the thing that
me feel better is the amount of people
and particularly men in my social
circles who were like yeah that guy's
crazy like straight up he is nuts
that is unacceptable and like he should
be totally shunned and in some ways
their arguments weren't that informed
either which was slightly frustrating I
was like could we have like a real
discussion about this that would be
interesting
oh so interesting but it's hard right
because I'm almost like in San Francisco
it's like you're you you have to be you
have to be so committed to a particular
mindset that if you don't have that
mindset you can't actually have like I
feel bad for any conservatives who live
here like you can't actually have a
conversation many ways but but I found
it interesting to say that I do feel
like a larger social shift that smells
that you were saying or it was like that
was a really unacceptable thing to do
and we could have had a new far more
nuanced discussion about the point he
was making and the ways in which he felt
marginalized in his society in his group
but instead everyone was like no fear
nuts and so I was like oh that's a good
monumental shift right because I
wouldn't have happened 20 years ago
maybe not even five not even five
honestly like certainly the same stuff
happened when I was in university it
just was a little quieter and like
Twitter wasn't around but yeah nobody
was nobody was in support right nobody
was the rallying cry people were like oh
yeah you are worse at math yeah it's one
of those things it's like you know the
I'm not the first person to make this
point but you know that like today it's
sort of globally considered not a great
thing to have slaves you know but he
talked about ethics evolving a brain but
not go back not that far and it was
completely acceptable yeah I have slaves
and so you know so it's like the fact
that like when I see a large number of
people horrified about things across you
know that's a broader demographic than
just a small slice then that's when you
can see you know the things are changing
and to your question Alan about
how do we change things for younger
women or just younger people in general
is I would say that if you're one if
you're a woman and you're doing if
you're a woman be visible because so
much has to do with representation like
I am obsessed about the brain if I had
known one neuroscientist male or female
in college you would be call it you'd
all call me dr. Bradford like really
like that's what I would have done
because I'm obsessed about the brain and
like I would have done that but I didn't
know anyone who's doing it so it wasn't
a no it wasn't something that was even
in my frame of reference and so if
you're a woman if you're female be
visible because there's someone out
there who will see you doing your thing
and it will give them a sense of
possibility for themselves if they
didn't have and you might never meet
that person you might never know who
that person is
and then be it yeah and then also you
know men doing something interesting
about changing the world and getting us
all on Team human be visible talk about
it be visible because there's men and
women out there who are gonna see what
you're doing and it's going to change
their realm of what's possible so
everybody who's on like the side of team
human the visible I love that all right
and a couple quick questions on the way
out I want to ask you three what is the
deepest emotion you've ever felt
yeah the question why am i Oh what am i
asking or why why yeah so so a lot of
what we do on simulation is we ask some
of humanity's deepest or maybe most
thought-provoking questions and we think
we you know this this question came a
long time ago and we ask it on the show
occasionally and it's one of a couple
that we have here on the way out but
just get really curious what you guys
think yeah absolutely
and I the here's the interesting thing
the question was can I answer the
question thanks John
the the here's the thing about me
answering the questions that I ask is
that I actually don't have answers
that's the interesting thing I that's
why I asked
yeah so maybe eventually in when I when
I taken enough inputs throughout life I
will finally come up with something I
think is an okay answer to that question
but it's very difficult yeah to do so
what do you guys for me it's really easy
it's anger because I don't get angry
very much but when I do I get angry a
bit because I think I'm expecting too
much from humans and so when they do
something totally totally different from
my expectations of what a human should
do it just it just pisses me off because
I don't have an understanding and I'm
angry because I don't have understanding
as to why they made that decision
because any any any that's not the right
way to say that any human that is for
humans like you said would not do
certain things and so that really just
pisses me off so what do you feel when
you're at your peak anger I feel
confusion because that I understand
they made that decision so yeah it's
just like the issue that we talked about
when I first got here right it was
really angry about that so I really
can't talk about it because the legal
situation but it's more of an inward
feeling or an outward feeling the anger
I think it's an inward feeling it's not
an outward it's not an outward feeling
so and I'm not talking about when I cope
with many human litters or something
like that I'm talking about when maybe
we were like a human like embezzles
money or our fire somebody that
shouldn't be fired like extreme things
right it just will deeply affect someone
else or a family or community that
pisses me off
hmm you too for me it's it's fear and I
find fear to be a really interesting
experience because for me it's like fear
is this immense full body thing and fear
is often closely coupled with like
adrenaline surge that comes thereafter
so if anybody who knows me or spends
times with any time with me knows that I
get obsessive with things like that like
fear and so I spend a lot of my time my
free time like riding motorcycles and
climbing and kite surfing and surfing
and and generally just for like yeah so
I think it's a really interesting thing
because I think the thing that I find
most fascinating about fear is that you
can just turn it off like you can forget
that you have fear which is a really
wild experience right you can do the
same thing two days in a row and one day
you're scared or out of your mind and
the next day you're just too tired to
remember that was horrifying and and I
just find that to be such a useful
experience for me and the rest of my
daily life because as as a VC on the
steward of somebody else's capital which
is the most horrifying thing to think
about right like the responsibility and
the pressure and the expectation and the
like self-serving goals of like wouldn't
it be nice to invest in something that
that changes the world somehow for the
better
those are so
panic-inducing for me that I have built
a life around exploring that emotion of
fear and figuring out how to how to
harness the adrenaline surge and and and
dampen the the panic state but I live in
some continual be honest game of pig
yeah which is funny because my fiancee
comes home and the way like I take
stress out if I don't um if I can't
actually you know like go ride a
motorbike around or something is I'll
just like obsessively start cleaning and
organizing I'm in the garage like you
know reshelving all the tools he's like
Oh something is like terribly wrong yeah
I think it's a full-body visceral
experience and I feel you on the anger
but for me my anger is just not useful
like when I'm angry I'm just in a blind
rage like I can't I can't like do
anything because then I take too like
getting like physically violent away
yeah you gotta teach me how to do that
like no amount of meditation doesn't
want to make me just like punch a wall
yeah for fear you're right about fear
especially in the space that we're in
but I probably shouldn't say this but I
take a lot of supplements ah jeez you're
like a lot of a lot of trips to the
vitamin shop to help me with that and I
just literally just tune it out love I
think love is the most powerful emotion
there is I think that my experience of
love is like the face of the Sun I think
that I think that our society has
has a sense that you know and not to it
this is completely separate but I think
our society says that anger and fear are
stronger because it seems more of a
point but the way that I think of it is
it's like a it's like a headlight that's
got mud on it and so people feel like
love is very diffuse because you can
only see a little bit of it through the
mud and then so you fall in love with
someone and it's like a scratch so
there's a lot of light in that point but
everything else is diffuse but one of
the things that happens is that you know
as we get as we peel our layers and a
lot of its mind training and a bunch of
other things but you know as you go to
the process that headlight gets the mud
comes off and then the love is like the
face of the Sun and that power you know
I you know I before I did what I'm doing
now I used to run a really eye operation
a really large video game I operated
World of Warcraft China it was the
largest stub of the largest game at the
time and so I have a big business
background and all of that and then I
went on a meditation retreat and I
walked out of that retreat happier than
I've ever been and completely unafraid
like zero fear I later found out that it
had a lot to do with a dramatic decline
in rumination which is basically the
inner chatter and mostly like says
everything's gonna go wrong and that's
wrong and that's what's going on in a
rumination yeah rumination and so it's
like you know that is what propelled me
to be you know to really dig into
psychology neuroscience and wanting to
use technology to help people get to
that place because it was all about
being on the back end of World of
Warcraft was all about scale and tech
and data and community and connection
people having like great relationships
so I don't have an immune response on
technology and humanity at all
because I saw it I lived it for six
years in China and so for me now you
know after I wasn't afraid is when I
found out like it wasn't until I wasn't
afraid that I realized how much fear
drove my life and it wasn't until I was
happy that I realized that before I was
optimistic and there wasn't actually
happy so you know having that experience
now today I am more driven by love than
I was by fear I'm more driven by like
love of humanity and you know what I
think is possible and all my business
instincts and all of that stuff goes to
you know need demanded means and I think
we have an opportunity I think we're at
a rare moment in time that hasn't
happened before but it's happening now
the next 10 to 15 years matter than most
we're laying the railroad track for or
we're setting the future for whether or
not we get Hunger Games or Starfleet and
that's what's happening right now and
love gets me out of bed in the morning
love you know powerful space love those
five hours of sleep love you know like
love writes that last email it's all
about love right now yeah Starfleet or
Hunger Games that's pretty interesting
binary vision and well I mean they're
they're turkeys and Starfleet and there
are good people in Hunger Games though
it's not completely binary but it's like
you know I'm really driven by I'm really
driven by the handover right yeah like
we need to have it we need it we are
responsible to have a handover that we
you know that that you know we can I
don't want to say proud of because it's
very egoic but it's response we're
responsible to have a good handover
stewards and were born into electricity
and running water and ubiquity and food
and education and also their kind of
stuff and just like can people worked
really hard to give that to us
so now it's up to us to leave behind a
really even better world okay last
question how do you use intuition in
your life hard question I I think true
intuition you don't even recognize
you're using it especially if like the
type of person I am I'm really good at
logic overlays and so I'll like have an
emotion and then be very very fast to
rationalize it and I'm particularly good
at that like if you need me I will I
will create a story for you and it's and
it's fine but I think I use intuition in
every moment right like my job is
sitting all day and having really
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed
entrepreneurs come in and say here's why
I'm going to change the world and here's
why I'm particularly well-suited to do
so and I have to basically make a snap
character judgment on very limited and
from it like wildly limited information
and it's a right it's it's a really
scary job because you you sit in this
very arbitrary judgment seat and it's
absolutely like at the end of the day
for me it's intuition and the way that I
think about it is there's lots of
brilliant investors out there and there
are some people who I will work very
very well with and that's the reason
that they happen to walk in the store
and we aligned on interest and vision
and ability to work together and we'll
build something beautiful together and
there's lots of people who are great
people who I have no business working
with and that's why I'm gonna have a
particular reaction to them and there's
lots of people who are kind of terrible
people and I might pick up on that too
and like let's not invest in that me
either
and so I think that I feel all of those
things and I feel them faster than I can
recognize them and then I'll be busy
layering on top all of the reasons that
I believe that right and it's and you
start overlaying like well this person
said this thing and they showed up
wearing this but at the end of the day
you just have like some gut reaction to
like pheromones or what like whatever
the
reaction is that happen to be a mix of
your brain in their brain and whatever
you had for breakfast that day and I
think that's the craziest part is it
like so much is just circumstance and
luck and timing and and I think
intuition just helps you sort yourself
out and happen to be in the right place
at the right time if you listen to it or
you can totally shut it out and just
right I have like I'm sure we all know
people who are just on Rails and like
just stopped listening to all outside
input and sometimes they're wildly
successful but most of the time they're
basically broods and so they become
really difficult to engage with but they
can be wildly successful if you're if
you're very intent on being in a
particular set of rails sorry that was
long I think I'm a hundred percent right
now I've been using the word universe so
we're gonna go with that but I mean I
just it leads to everything that I do
because when I don't bad things happen
and things get out of order so it's
about that feeling how do you tap into
the spirit feeling or the universe
feeling how are you led by that how do
you what does it mean to go off of that
feeling and bad things I think for me
just growing up in a Christian household
I just kind of helped set that
foundation I don't go to church anymore
and all that I've woken up from that but
I think that there's some roots in it
some basic spiritual principles that I
learned at a very young age then I'm
just able to carry over into meditation
so I like to mix things up so that's how
I process it and just because I've been
doing it for so long it just it just
naturally turns on it's on all the time
so much to the point a lot of people
actually think I'm clairvoyant I don't
think I'm clairvoyant I just think that
I feared out how to listen
and how to be still when I need to be
still and how to be still while you're
still walking down the street and you
know and living during the day so that's
good how to be still when you're walking
down the street you're so got to get
things done and make decisions or the
CEO of a company and stuff like that or
you know especially for us we decided to
bootstrap and not take investor capital
it's really it's a really weird as an
investor as an entrepreneur I'm anti VC
but as a VC in it but I am also a VC oh
it's really it's really I'm in a really
rare place in FinTech but as a boost as
us women we felt like in order to
protect our interests in our own company
and the innovations of financial
innovations that were there were
creating to bootstrap I mean you have to
have a lot of faith to to go to Kenya
with like less than a hundred dollars in
your pocket and just know that
everything is going to be ok you get
there right so that's intuition telling
you it's going to be ok and it was ok
once we got there but stuff like that
that's how we I use intuition and
building my companies and stuff so when
it looks doom and gloom just dips it's
that little voice telling you that
everything is going to be ok right don't
freak out just just just you know just
work it out and just just keep going
okay I'm gonna be super quick um I used
the biology so you know on the Serengeti
like we all developed the ability to you
know look the most important things were
to know like who you could trust who you
coulda lie with and you know and and
other things like that and so you know
you we have a hundred and twenty two
facial expressions where we only control
nine when you are talking to someone and
they like what you're saying their
pupils dilate slightly something that
you can't even you know you like
consciously you don't get up like your
body picks it up because we are designed
to pick that or not designed we evolved
to be able to pick that up and so when
one of the benefits of meditation is
that when you when you you're not
running a lot of inner chatter you can
actually like sense what your body picks
up we're broadcasting constantly and
people are constantly broadcasting to us
so now that I understand that and I can
be incredibly quiet like when I'm
talking to someone I'm not thinking
about anything else I'm totally there
and so as a result it's like and then
when you're listening to what your body
thinks about the person you get like
tons of information and also when you
really listen to someone they'll tell
you everything mm-hmm so you know you
don't even it doesn't they'll just tell
you everything if you really really
listen so that's it you'd be surprised
yeah Wow
this is this is definitely one of my
favorite times I'm like I love this so
much you know I do and thank you for
having us I this we got to do this more
often you know women in alliance number
two let's go let's get it going you know
let's get the production rolling we
yeah thanks thanks shoutouts are on for
directing and producing and the this
there is still a lot to explore and
unpack and understand and embody embody
and bring it into our practice on earth
so thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you yes round applause thank
you